[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Louis Gray here, from
Mountain View, California from
Google headquarters.
I'm really excited to talk about
today's event, focus on
organizational manipulation.
I brought with me one of my
good friends and great
colleagues, Brian Fitzpatrick,
all the way down from Chicago.
Welcome Brian, or as
I call you, Fitz.
I guess that's how most people
call you these days.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Yeah, most
people call me Fitz.
LOUIS GRAY: That's good.
It's easy to understand,
easy to remember.
It's great to have
you on board.
We've been talking quite
a bit over several
different Google I/Os.
I think I see you a
few times a year.
And one of the discussions you
regularly do with Ben--
Ben Collins-Sussman, who could
not be here today--
is on organizational
manipulation.
So let's start right
at the top.
What is this all about?
Why do you have these big words,
which really just mean
office politics, right?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Yeah, we
purposely chose the words,
"organizational manipulation"
because even though it is
politics, we wanted to focus
people on the fact that it's
an active bending, an
organization, whether it be a
company or any organization, to
your will, to some extent,
to making things happen.
And it's an element, I think,
something engineers can do
that isn't a technical solution,
but one that allows
you to leverage your
technical skills.
And so it's sort of a
force multiplier.
LOUIS GRAY: So you mentioned two
things that catch my mind
right away.
First, you say engineers.
I assume that there are
more employees in the
world beyond engineers.
Maybe engineers are the best
employees, and we can talk
about that.
But also, bending a big
organization to your will
might sound impossible,
especially for an individual
contributor, maybe somebody who
hasn't been at a company
for very long.
So what is that can have
somebody look at this type of
scenario, where an individual
can have a big impact on a
company and make that change?
What does it take?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Before I
start with what it takes, I'd
say the reason we focus on
engineers, I think is because
I think engineers typically
spend a lot more effort
working on technical solutions,
and think that the
sort of people part is
tangential and unimportant.
The point is, that with a
little dosage of this
organizational manipulation,
you can get a lot further.
You can make a lot more
things happen.
So that's my objective
with that.
Now as to how you can do it,
I think, first of all,
acknowledging that it's
something worth spending your
time on is the most
important thing.
And so I tried to explain
it as it's like
a lever and a fulcrum.
You may be able to pick
up that really heavy
object and move it.
But it's probably going to be
a lot easier if you use a
lever and fulcrum, or a
forklift, or whatever
the case may be.
So the way that you implement
that is by basically
understanding how people
work in a company.
LOUIS GRAY: One thing
I've experienced--
I've been at a number of
companies in my 15 years in
the Valley.
And I remember sometimes people
would get especially
worked up at upper management,
and feel like the only way to
get something solved
was to make change.
And we'd often talk about
this political move.
And one thing--
I remember talking to
a guy and, he said,
Louis, you know what?
The people who play politics,
don't talk about it.
And you just kind of
do it quietly.
Like, that guy's a snake.
Or he does something.
What is it that you're doing
that kind of breaks the rules
to talk about the
political side?
Aren't you're kind of being
subversive here?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I
like being subversive.
I don't think it's subversive.
I don't talk about it.
I think it's worth talking about
because I learned the
hard way, and how to make
things happen in bigger
companies, how to work within
the organization instead of
against it.
And I think that I found these
tips and tricks, along with
Ben, because we've
been looking into
this thing for years.
And I think it's worthwhile
to think about them
just because it's--
I want engineers, in general, to
have a stronger say in what
they're doing.
I want them to have
a bigger impact.
And a lot of times, their voices
aren't heard in the
organization because they're
too busy, heads
down writing code.
That's often the solution, if
you're an engineer, is you see
some problem, well, I'm just
going to work harder, and
write more code, and write
better code, and
make a better product.
And that will win.
Unfortunately, that's
not always the case.
So by sharing these general
tips and tricks, it's not
something that anyone who knows
them, will say, oh my
god, that's terrible.
You shouldn't talk about that.
It's much more of a--
I think most people are more
likely to say, well, that's
kind of obvious.
I'm sort of doing that
to some extent.
But a lot of engineers, I think,
abhor the thought of
doing that because
they see people
who are openly political.
They see people who are
interested in showing that
they're having an impact, but
not interested actually in
having an impact.
So the people that focus a lot
of energy into looking
impactful tend to make the
people who are focusing energy
into having impactful abhor
that idea of showing that
you're having impact.
LOUIS GRAY: And I think some of
that, also, is a little bit
of push pull between engineering
and marketing, in
terms of saying, let's go out
and make something incredible,
or let's just tell the world
it's incredible, maybe when
it's not ready.
I've been somebody who's worn
that marketing hat for a long
time and always tried to have a
way to at least communicate
with the engineers.
How do I speak their language,
and bring it to a point where
they understand that what we're
trying to do is tell the
truth, but bring it
to more people.
And you talk about this sharing
mentality, of being
able to speak up
on your behalf.
But what are some of those tips
and tricks that you refer
to that a typical engineer
can either
recognize or start applying?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I would
say that the first thing
is to understand that the
marketing part is incredibly
important and good, if
you've got a product.
The general thing is that when
you see case after case of
products where marketing gets
up and they show all this
sizzle, and then they pick
up the big cover,
and there's no steak.
And I think that makes
people gun-shy.
So if you acknowledge the fact
that hey, we've got awesome
steak here.
It's OK to dress it up a little
bit and have this
marketing flourish.
Beyond that, I think a lot of it
is just respecting the fact
that there's a lot of really
good marketers out there.
I think one of the things,
most valuable things I've
learned in my career over the
past, gosh, many, many years,
is that there are people who
don't do engineering jobs--
whether it's marketers,
salespeople, PR people, policy
people, lawyers--
who are really, really freaking
good at their job.
And that suddenly changes your
attitude towards these people.
And I think a lot of engineers
have had bad
experiences with that.
I think most engineers I know
have worked in the small
company with the bad salesperson
who doesn't
understand the product, or who
isn't a very good salesperson,
or just is a jerk to them.
And they get burned by that.
And they feel like they're
going to--
You arrange your life
around that.
LOUIS GRAY: I think everybody
has bad experiences.
I don't want to say, for better,
for worse because
they're usually for the worse.
And what I find is when you
go through this type of
experience, it's what you
end up being on the way
through at the end.
Did you learn from it?
Did it become more refined?
Are you better off from having
had a bad time, albeit someone
who operated in a manner that
you weren't accustomed to.
I think as someone who's been
in the Valley for a while,
I've had bosses that I was a
really good friend with.
I've had bosses who gave me
really good instruction, but
didn't want to hang out
on the weekends.
And I've had bosses who didn't
really understand what it was
that I was bringing to the table
and it took a lot more
convincing than I would
have expected.
So how can somebody who's in
maybe a tough spot with
management, and feels like
they're producing a good
steak, as you put it, how can
they try and make their case?
What is it that they can to
help understand different
communication styles,
for example, to
take that next step?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I think
the first thing to do is
understand that companies
are made of people.
It's not software.
It's not building.
It's made of people.
And you need to learn how to
navigate these people.
And sometimes that might take
you a GPS, dump truck, and a
flashlight, a dump truck full of
bread crumbs to leave your
little trail.
But it's important to
be able to do that.
And so the first and foremost
thing is understand that there
are different kinds of
companies, just like there are
different kinds of people.
There's the ideal company, which
is where everything is
very lovely, think
of it as a lovely
Japanese garden or something.
And then there's the actual
company, which is like
somebody ripped the hood off an
old car and puts a bunch of
dirt and flowers in it or
something like that.
So the first thing I would say
that you could do is to
understand the organization
of the company.
And you'd never learn this from
looking at the org chart.
Because there are ways that
power flows through companies,
and it's typically not through
the org chart.
There are people who have
influence in your company that
have been there a long time.
There are people who have
influence in your company that
have been there less time.
Maybe they have industry
influence.
Or they're well-known
and well-respected.
Or they just have the
ear of the CEO or
something like that.
Knowing who these people are
and being able to talk to
them, being able to earn their
respect, I would say, is an
important part of that.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
Now, one thing that you were
talking about in terms of an
individual contributor level--
sometimes there's a big gap
between the people who are
coding and the people
who are managing.
And what often happens as
people's careers progress is
they stop coding once they
get into management.
I've seen a lot of this happen
even at a company like Google,
where you'll have
a VP who hasn't
touched code in a while.
Do you find that as you move up
and start to manage people,
and managing people becomes to
be a bigger part of your job,
do you not need the little
people anymore?
Do you kind of move beyond that
and say, it's a us versus
them mentality?
Or how do you avoid that
type of separation?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I would
say you would do that at
your own peril.
There's always going to be a
separation that's perceived
from people in a lower parts
of an organization.
I don't think it's perceived of
as big of a separation as
you get further up in the
organization or up the
management chain.
But I think as you move into
a leadership position or
management--
I prefer to talk about
leadership rather than
management because I always
think that managers are
concerned with how people do
something, and leaders are
more concerned with what
they're doing.
But as you move in the
leadership position, you'll
find the biggest challenge
is that you've got--
The first challenge is that
you have your previous
conceptions of every bad
manager you ever had.
That's why so many engineers I
know are horrified of ever
moving into management because
they're like, I don't want to
just write email, and I don't
want to be like the micro
manager, and I don't want to do
all these terrible things.
And the big secret is
you don't have to.
Your role is what you make it.
But the biggest challenge is
that you now have two bosses
or multiple bosses.
One is the person that you
report to on the org chart.
And the other person, other
boss, as I say it, is everyone
that reports to you.
Those are the people.
We call this managing up
and managing down.
And you really need to be good
at both of those things.
The organizational manipulation
component is more
about the managing up and
beyond your manager.
The good leadership portion is
more about being, I would say,
a servant leader.
The best managers that I've
ever had at Google or
elsewhere have been what I would
call servant leaders,
meaning they're there
to help me out.
When I first started at Google,
Ben and I were the
first engineers in
Chicago office.
Eric Schmidt came out
to meet with me.
And I had all these things
prepared to talk to him about
and report on what we were doing
and where we were going.
And we had this very
casual meeting.
And halfway through it, he
asked me what I needed.
He said, what can
I do for you?
What do you need?
And I was looking through
my notes.
I had no answer prepared
for this.
But that is servant leadership
right there.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
It kind of reminds me
of someone I think
we both know well.
It's DeWitt Clinton.
DeWitt's another great guy who
focuses on open source and
standards here at Google.
And there's a phrase he told
me several years ago.
He said, I go to meetings, so
my people don't have to.
He calls himself like--
The buffer was him sitting in
that room and fighting on
behalf of his team, and giving
them the air cover that they
needed to go and get
their jobs done.
And it's interesting.
We've talked a little bit about
that leadership strategy.
But in terms of the organization
manipulation, if
you are a fantastic engineer,
you're a great individual
contributor, how do you look at
something in your team, in
your company, that you
want to change and
start to affect that?
Do you have to understand what
the power brokers are, or what
the deliverables are that
are important to the
company as a whole?
Or how do you start
to make change?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I would
come at it first from
understanding your company.
So first of all, you have to
understand what you can do in
your company, what you
can get away with.
On the continuum of an ideal
company versus the worst
company in the world,
where does your
company fall on that?
What can you do and get away
with in the beg for
forgiveness versus asking
for permission?
And what do you have to ask
for permission to do?
So understanding your company
a bit is the first thing.
But beyond that, I would say a
lot of this can be done by
pursuing responsibility in your
company, looking to pick
up things that other people
may not be interested in,
questioning things.
So you're going to
want to know--
If you're told to do something
or your company's doing
something, you might want to
ask, why are we doing this?
Give me some more information.
Helping the company to make
better decisions.
Now, some companies it's not
acceptable to question things.
Other companies, it's
encouraged.
And again, that falls back
on the good versus ideal.
But more importantly, I would
say as part of the foundation
is to communicate proactively.
A lot of people just assume that
because someone is the
director or vice president
or manager, that they're
omniscient, and they know
everything that's going on,
and they know exactly
what you're
thinking, what you need.
And because they didn't give it
to you, they're trying to
screw you over.
What I tell people who report
to me when I get a new
employee, I say, look, if I'm
doing something that you don't
like or that bothers you, or you
think is wrong, I beg you
to let me know about it.
Because if you don't tell me,
I guarantee you one thing--
I'm going to keep doing it.
And it's not malicious and
it's not cruel-hearted.
It's just the way things are.
I can't see that thing that
I'm doing that's--
And oftentimes, if you're a good
leader or a good manager,
not only will you work to change
that or to understand
why this is having this effect
on this person, but you can do
something that is another sort
of secret weapon, in general,
which is apologizing when
you make a mistake.
It's really hard to
do sometimes.
LOUIS GRAY: And you mentioned
keeping people informed and
knowing that they're
not omniscient.
One thing that I was almost
taunted by when people knew I
was joining Google, they said,
oh, good luck reporting and
writing your snippets and doing
your OKRs, and the types
of things that we do at Google
to keep people updated and
keep us looking at
long-term goals.
How do you find that things like
weekly reports or staff
meetings and such can be used
to communicate both up the
chain and down the chain?
What do you find valuable, and
what's a waste of time?
To be honest.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So having
been in and worked in a number
of different companies, I
love weekly snippets.
And what we do every
Monday morning--
LOUIS GRAY: Tell some of
the viewers who don't
know what these are.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
Every Monday morning, I come
into work and I get a nag-mail
reminder-- because I would
forget everything otherwise--
that tells me, this is what you
did last week, your little
three, four bullet points.
What are you doing this week?
And I sit down, and I correct
what I did last week because I
thought I was going to do
this last week, and I
actually did this.
And then I say, oh, this is
the three or four bullet
points of what I plan on doing
this week, top-level things
I'm working on.
And the great thing about this
is it goes out in an email to
people who work with me, but
it goes up into my internal
profile or whatever you
want to call it, so
everybody can see that.
Anybody can, [INAUDIBLE], they
can go here and they can look.
This is what Fitz has been doing
in the past few months,
like my internal resume.
This is what Fitz has
done at Google over
the past eight years.
I think that having that open
and available for everybody is
very valuable.
I worked at another company
where we had to do weekly
detailed logging what we
did for every hour.
It wasn't that we were
billing time.
It was just this is how
they wanted to do it.
They wanted to be able to divide
it up per project and
as a number of hours and
a percent of your time.
And it all went to my manager.
And you know what
happened then?
Nothing.
It went nowhere.
So I would say in that
case, it was a
complete waste of time.
Because it took me 40 minutes to
do this report some weeks.
I always tell people that if it
takes you more than four or
five minutes to do
your snippets,
it's a waste of time.
So I would say the fact that
it's visible internally by
everyone, I think that's
the kind of thing
that makes it valuable.
The same goes with OKRs.
I think OKRs, as a set of goals
for what you're going to
do this quarter, are very
valuable, not only to help you
and your team focus, but also
to be able to look back and
say, did I get everything done
I wanted to get done?
Is it because I wasn't as
productive as I wanted to be?
Is it because I was too
ambitious in my goals?
And then you set the next
quarter's goals.
And over time, you can sort
of calibrate yourself.
You get a better feel for what
you can do in a quarter and
what you can't do.
And so again, those
are visible to
everyone in the company.
And I think that that
broad internal
visibility is very valuable.
LOUIS GRAY: I'm looking over
here at this book.
I feel like we're on one of the
shows where I'm hawking a
book and telling people
to buy this book.
But buy this book.
"Team Geek," from Brian
Fitzpatrick and Ben
Collins-Sussman.
It talks about a software
developer's guide to working
well with others.
And so a couple questions
on this.
First, is this working with
other software developers?
Other humans?
Other non-software developers?
What do you mean by others?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: It starts
with understanding yourself,
which is sort of step one.
It moves onto your team, to
managers and leadership.
So there's a chapter on how
to be a good leader.
And part of that chapter is how
to manage your manager.
It's how to work with
managers or leaders.
We talked a little about
that earlier.
Then we talk about dealing
with jerks in the
organization, what we call
poisonous people.
And then organizational
manipulation is part of that.
So it's dealing with
an entire company.
And lastly, we devote a bit of
time into users and to how to
relate to your users.
So it's a broad spectrum of
others, of working well with
other people.
But more than anything, it's
about the importance of
leveraging the human factor, and
how you can basically get
more done with less effort by
spending a little bit of time
in that lubrication, we call
it, the human element of
programming.
LOUIS GRAY: You mentioned
poisonous people.
And that's really hard to
nail down sometimes.
I was at a company at one
point where we did a
reduction in force.
We needed to do it.
The company was at a point where
we would only get to
break-even if we made changes.
And it seemed to me that we
reduced force by eliminating
people who were already negative
about the company.
And it was like, you take
the cancer out and
the body was better.
And it was a really interesting
transformation to
see within a quarter, people
felt better about themselves.
You didn't have that
negative element.
Have you ever been in
a scenario where the
organization itself
seemed toxic, and
it was almost untenable?
And then what does a person do
when they're surrounded by
naysayers or people who are
waiting for severance, rather
than waiting for
something good?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well,
that's really hard.
And I acknowledge that there
are companies like that.
I've always considered myself
really fortunate to be working
in tech and to be working
at Google.
And I've had the opportunity
to work at other companies
like Apple.
And I've had many opportunities,
so I feel like
I could go and find another
job if I needed to.
And it's harder for
some people to do.
But I would say that when you're
surrounded by this sort
of thing, it tends to be a
cultural problem, if you're
surrounded by a culture of
negativity or a culture of
aggression.
Like we've seen companies, as
well as open source projects,
that are based on people being
very abusive to each other.
And they're like, well, you
know, we're shipping software.
This is OK.
And I don't think it is OK.
I think it's inefficient.
And I'm not going to say it's
morally wrong, but I'm just
going to say that if I had a
choice between spending more
time shipping product or more
time yelling with other
people, I'm going to choose
shipping product.
And I feel like having
a good atmosphere--
And negativity isn't
always bad.
I mean, a lot of the times
having someone with a
controversial position or
someone who doesn't agree with
everyone else is very valuable,
as a way of helping
you make a better decision.
So I think these people
can be very valuable.
The poisonous people
part is more about
addressing bad behaviors.
The title of that chapter,
I think is a little
controversial.
Again, like organizational
manipulation, we're
deliberately trying
to provoke people.
But it's not about the people.
It's about the behaviors.
And if you address the
behaviors and not the
individuals, you'll wind up with
individuals who can learn
a little bit about things that
they were doing that might not
have been having the effect
that they were having.
This has happened time and again
where someone was doing
something that was devastating
the other members of the team.
And I pulled them aside and I
said, are you aware that when
you do A, people are upset
and they're really,
really mad at you?
Really?
And they've been floored.
And this has happened
time and time again.
I said, yes.
I said, I don't feel like you're
doing this maliciously,
but people feel that you're
doing this maliciously.
Well, they shouldn't.
And that "shouldn't" is
always a trigger word.
That's a word that should make
you think, ah, maybe we're
getting off into theory land as
opposed to reality world.
By addressing the behavior in
many cases, we wind up with an
even better person on our team
who's more aware of what
they're doing.
We've got, they already
know what's going on.
The team already knows him, as
opposed to just saying, oh
this guy's an idiot.
Flip the bozo bit.
We'll get rid of him and we'll
bring somebody else in.
LOUIS GRAY: I've heard theory
land is a very nice place.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: In theory,
it's perfect.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
So we've talked about having
to be a challenging
organization, working with
challenging people.
Have you ever tried to
make a change and the
organization said no?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Oh, absolutely.
All the time.
There's a difference,
I think, between--
I'm a big fan of fail early
and fail often.
Let's put it that way.
I often get crazy ideas.
And before I go right in front
of the CEO with my idea, or
try and get headcount, or try
and build a product, I will
often-- as you know, because
I've talked to you about
things like this in the past--
I'll often grab people I trust
and I know within the company
in a one-on-one, and grab a cup
of coffee and say, hey,
I'm having this crazy idea.
What do you think?
And sometimes they'll say,
that's completely crazy and
you shouldn't do it.
You're bats.
LOUIS GRAY: There's that
word shouldn't again.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Shouldn't.
Exactly.
That's a different kind
of shouldn't.
Other times, they'll say,
oh, that's interesting.
I think there is
a problem here.
Have you thought about this,
this, this, and this?
So that usually helps me get to
a point where by the time
I'm looking to move things
into the organization and
bigger, I have an idea
of whether it's the
right thing or not.
And it still might
get shot down.
And the point that we make in
our chapter about organization
manipulation, is that there's a
lot of different things you
can do to facilitate change in
your company, or your group,
or your organization.
And make sure that you're
being smart about it.
Make sure that you're
trying these things.
You're acknowledging that humans
are imperfect, and in
some cases, indifferent.
But if you can't affect any
change, and you've tried and
tried again, it's foolish
to continue
throwing energy into that.
And you should probably think
about if not looking for
another job, at least
start training.
Get some training to
learn some skills.
Update your resume.
And then start poking around.
Because one pattern that I've
seen-- you talked about
companies where there are people
sitting around waiting
for pension, that
sort of thing--
is that if people are in a
corporation or organization
where they can't affect change,
and they're very
passionate and enthusiastic,
they'll affect change.
They'll sabotage.
Because you can always
sabotage.
And that is a dangerous
place to be.
That's why I really
think that.
I've seen good people in
companies switch from being
the strongest advocates to the
worst enemy because they
really wanted to
affect change.
And they're so upset and so
disillusioned, that they're
going to make change
one way or another.
LOUIS GRAY: And I was
thinking about this.
I realized that a lot of our
discussion already has been a
little bit negative.
And I don't want to overdo it
and close on a sorrow note.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well,
anti-patterns
are memorable though.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah.
And this is clearly my fault
because I'm the one firing you
these questions.
There was this one boss I had
where we were talking about
career progression.
And when you get a boss who will
actually sit you down and
say, this is where I see
you going, and you
remind me of me.
And you start to be like
friendly and chummy.
It can be very helpful,
as you know.
And I remember, I
spoke with him.
He said, you're going to be VP
of marketing at this place.
But what you need to do is you
need to understand not just
the corporate marketing
you've done.
You need to have product
marketing experience.
I'd like you to be product
management as well.
And so you would start to have
more skills and more buckets.
And you talked about possibly
either updating your resume or
getting another set of skills.
Should somebody be looking to
rounding their resume out, so
that they're not so
niche focused?
And how do they go about
starting to get, I guess, the
next bowling pin in that
analogy, to round out their
resume and have a job that's a
little bit different, so they
know it even better?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: I
think it depends.
Different companies have
different ways of doing this.
One of the neat things about
Google is, we talked about 20%
time in the past.
And that's something, I think,
that you have to earn.
You can't just show up on day
one and start doing that.
But I think if you start taking
a little bit of time to
do other things within
the organization--
and it might be outside of your
normal work hours even--
but that's a way, a relatively
cheap way of exploring new
things and finding new things
and trying them out.
I mean, I came to writing
software and software
engineering very late in life.
I think I was 24 when I started
programming in earnest.
And I got there because I kept
trying things until I found
something I really liked.
And holy cow, was I
crazy about it.
So I would say kibitzing is
really effective in that case.
It's just trying out
different things
until you find something.
Once you've found something you
love, I think it's OK to
really dig deep and
maybe become a
domain expert on that.
Otherwise, you see a lot of
people who are, I'd say,
dilettantes because there's
a lot of different things
they're interested in.
They're good at a lot of
different things and they try
a lot of different things.
So a lot of that depends on
what you're interested in.
LOUIS GRAY: I wanted to bring
up one point of fact before
we're all done.
You started the Google
Chicago office.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Engineering
office.
LOUIS GRAY: Engineering
So you had to manipulate the
organization, first of all, to
let you live out there instead
of living over here in
Mountain View.
Every time I see Fitz is coming
out to San Francisco or
Mountain View, I'm like stay.
We don't want you to leave.
And you keep telling me no.
How did you make that happen,
as best as you're
able to tell us.
How did you get them to see this
is what I'm doing and I'm
planting my flag?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I think
they didn't know what
they were getting into.
So Ben and I actually, we both
interviewed at the same time.
And we both said we really
want to stay in Chicago.
And some folks at Google
said, well, we
have this sales office.
And you're going to be working
a project that's fairly
distributed.
It was a different world
eight years ago.
And so they let Ben and I
start things off there.
And we hired a third guy, third
engineer, about four
months later.
And for a long time, it
was the three of us.
And so I think, don't ever
discount luck, the luck of the
draw, whether it was persistence
or people inside
of Google advocating
for me or whatever.
But it was the timing.
It was luck of the draw.
It was somebody saw
and decided to
take a chance, I guess.
So I'm very grateful for that.
Because I really wasn't--
when Google first approached
me and said, why don't you
move to Mountain View?
I said, forget it, man.
They said, well, how
about New York?
I said, that's not in
Chicago either.
I guess, we were
so very lucky.
LOUIS GRAY: Very cool.
Well, the great thing that's
lucky for us is we get to have
you back the next two days.
So thanks for coming by.
Tomorrow, we're going to talk
about Data Liberation project.
It's something that's near
and dear to you,
near and dear to me.
And in two days, we're going to
talk about the Transparency
Report, and all the work that
you've done to help the world
understand exactly what Google
goes through when we try to
get our data to you,
and vice versa.
So thanks for coming over and
meeting with us today, Fitz,
and talking with us.
This has been Louis Gray at
Google Developers Live.
We'll see you tomorrow.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]